this is not able to hurt now they do  with ball and body movement they are  very astute with kevin direct walks into  that free  fighting knocks one down field goal here  by Saturday all day if I walked away  it's forbidden get some old folks lots  of files and just beat all golf very  well for me  [Applause]  and the possession before you sought  directions come down the middle and  that's too easy  [Applause]  and fire  [Applause]  the lab confirmed yes the rat play by  Anderson chapter step  our bike KB a little rip move right here  there Anderson gets caught with his  hands down and trying to dig and Kady is  just too long for that this is this you  know he gets that little hence that  little head start on you  [Applause]  [Music]  five steals got to sell five ten eleven  rebounds it's really playing well to  20th birthday  by ambushing direct private space  [Applause]  Hey